[Music]
alright guys Billboard Music Awards
how you feeling going into are you more
or less nervous this time around no baby
honor it's uh it's more nervous cuz you
know it's it's a world premiere right
never expected like something like this
but beyond our dream so it'd be a lie
affair like less nervous if BTS was
nervous at the 2018 Billboard Music
Awards we'd never know it after owning
the red carpet in colorful coordinating
looks the powerhouse kpop band dominated
the stage performing their new single
fake gloves
[Applause]
not only were fans starstruck
celebrities were - the guys posed for
photos with Pharrell John Legend Taylor
Swift and even ran into DJ Khaled he
they call you oh that's right you see he
was with BTS last week to talk about
their new album love yourself tear they
gushed over how much support they've
gotten from fans sometimes really feel
like we're getting we're getting like
more love than even we deserved so we
really tried to all we can do is like
all we can give back is that you know we
focus on our you know car gratis music
that's all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]